I'll be talking back that the comedian
there and then like one restroom so you
have to wait for Gabriel lessieur to use
it so you know he blow that up oh yeah
it's funny like as big as he was he
never broke a toilet on the road I did
really just sitting on it yeah we're in
Oxnard you know when you have to go fast
you put on your pants
and like I have a problem I never sat
down slowly on the toilet I'm used to
those how they unified school district
school toilets at the housing project
toilets uh-huh so what I said it was
like this was a hotel toilet so my room
was on top no my room was on on top
right so I used that toilet and then
like Oh water came out so I went
downstairs to Gabriel SES bathroom
what's going on I don't know man Tina
toilet broken man you go check the coat
check it out there's water everywhere
yeah someone to go use the restroom
oh this how irresponsible I was not even
like offer to pay for the toilet or I
just say sorry and then Gabriel got
charged for it you think I can imagine
him going down one of my friend bought
the toilet show the new fat-ass right
right you see just sat down too hard
just like a relief like ah yeah and then
almost when I was that perfectly in the
hole I must have sat in a corner and I'm
heavier now an editorial broke the water
disc shout out how long were you on tour
with a Gabriel
[Music]
[Music]
high breath